je mesure le poids de l'histoire sa
rigueur sa grandeur
françois mitterrand et le président de
la république c'était le 10 mai 1981 il
ya tout juste 40 ans
une consécration pour le socialiste
après plus de 25 ans de course à
l'elysée
1965 première campagne présidentielle
pour mitterrand unique candidat de la
gauche
il est soutenu par la sf bio le parti
radical mais aussi par les communistes
je suis candidat contre le général de
gaulle contre lui seul car lui seul
qu'on à droite première candidature
présidentielle
les premières défaites le général de
gaulle est élu mais l'ambition de
mitterrand est intacte 1971 il est
investi premier secrétaire d'un tout
nouveau parti le parti socialiste
c'était lors du congrès d'epinay
et il se place en leader de l'opposition
celui d'une icône en bas la rupture avec
l'ordre établi
politique le vote soit secondaire avec
la société capitaliste celui là veulent
aider il ne peut pas être adhérent du
parti socialiste en ligne de mire
l'elysée toujours mais en 1974
rebelote nouvelle douche froide pour le
candidat de la gauche unie
vous l'avez par le ch mitterrand le pôle
liqueurs vous n'avez pas c'est valéry
giscard d'estaing qui remporte
l'élection au second tour je rêvais les
12 millions et 600 à 700 milles
françaises et français qui en second
temps sur mon nom ont réalisé le plus
grand rassemblement de notre histoire
contemporaine sur les vidéos de la bonne
malgré la défaite
mitterrand persiste il reste l'homme
fort de la gauche 1981 pour la troisième
fois il se lance encore dans la course à
l'elysée c'est lors du congrès de
créteil qu'il est désigné candidat par
le parti socialiste candidat des
socialistes
je veux l'être aussi je dois l'être du
rassemblement populaire si nécessaire à
la sauvegarde de la démocratie à la
transformation de notre société et à la
grandeur de la france
cette fois c'est fait françois
mitterrand prend sa revanche contre le
valéry giscard d'estaing et il sera même
réélu sept ans plus tard face à jacques
chirac
[Musique]